there are concerns that people at some
public gatherings are not taking
precautions against covid dr peter hotez
is a professor of pediatrics and
molecular biology at baylor college of
medicine and he joins us now to discuss
good morning good to see you
good morning nice to see you so dr hotez
when you see these large crowds and
packed stadiums what goes through your
mind
well what goes through my mind vlad is
that we're having this incredible surge
right now of coven 19 although it's
unevenly distributed in the united
states right now in the south the south
is on fire
and in terms of this raging
epidemic in terms of number of new cases
especially among young people
and now we've got a hundred thousand
americans in hospitals right now as as
we're speaking and the deaths are
climbing to over 1500 uh deaths a day
almost all of them
among the unvaccinated and so it
troubles me that we somehow decided this
is over and the delta variant now is
surging across america along those lines
there's a lot of talk about boosters and
according to the new york times federal
health officials have told the white
house
it's time to scale back that booster
plan for a third shot what is your take
on some of the mixed messages that we're
getting right now around it
yeah and i think it's really important
dana to break it down by individual
vaccines so the pfizer biantec vaccine
the data coming out of israel is showing
that the effectiveness of the vaccine
has gone down from over 90 to 40 to 50
percent over
over a six to eight month time period
and that's actually to be expected based
on how the vaccines were initially
rolled out when those first two doses
were
spaced so closely together so many of us
always thought this would be a three
dose vaccine and now we're seeing that
decline the good news
is that we're not seeing a lot of
breakthrough hospitalizations or deaths
but we are seeing breakthrough cases and
breakthrough long covid so i think
that's going to be the basis for the
third immunization and the the fda verb
committee meeting is scheduled to meet
september 17th so just in about a week
and a half to kind of weigh in on this
and hopefully we'll with with for the
pfizer biontech vaccine will now move
forward and that third immunization for
the other two we we still have not seen
a lot of evidence of breakthrough
infections or hospitalizations but my
guess is that's probably going to happen
as well over time and we'll see third
immunizations for the moderna vaccine
and the second immunization for the j
and j vaccine dr hotez we often keep
hearing about the second wave the third
wave i believe we're in the fourth wave
and now we're hearing more about this
new variant that's coming out of
columbia what more can you tell us and
how will that impact us getting to herd
immunity
well we you know we have enough to worry
about right now with the delta variant
and let's get our way through that i'm
looking at that mu variant
that that could be troubling but right
now it's around it's not really gaining
ascendancy i think the key is to
vaccinate our way out of delta but the
problem is
the bar is really high i mean we're
looking at the need to vaccinate up to
90 percent of the u.s population and it
may require
three doses of of the mrna vaccines in
order to make that happen and you might
say well gee that's not possible well
the answer is of course it is we do it
every we do it every year for measles we
should be able to reach that bar dr
hotez we're seeing an increase in cases
among children right now many of whom
can't get vaccinated so what needs to be
done to keep kids safe as they prepare
to go back to school
yeah really important question and the
answer is
get every anyone who's eligible to be
vaccinated get vaccinated because what
we're learning now is that the little
kids who are under the age of 12 not old
enough to be vaccinated are often
getting infected from
unvaccinated adults either unvaccinated
adults in the home and we even have a
report now from the centers for disease
control of an unvaccinated teacher so
it's really key that anyone is eligible
to be vaccinated get that vaccine and
really in the school setting right in my
opinion anyone over the age of 12
who goes into that school has to be
vaccinated and that will make a big
impact and we're already seeing it you
know if you look at what's going on in
the new england states where they've
done such a good job of vaccinating all
of the adults and just about all of the
adolescents they're not seeing a lot of
kids little kids get infected very
different down here in the south where
tragically adults and adolesce and their
and their adolescent kids have been
defiant of getting vaccinated so we have
to fix that
dr peter hotez we thank you so much for
joining us this morning